herzlich willkommen zurück zu Porsche
Trailer dem Format in dem ich mich
Versuche von nichts ja das hier ist
nichts zu einem Porsche hoch zu arbeiten
unser erster Versuch nach verlorenen
Golfbällen zu tauchen lief zu Beginn
besser als gedacht es gab aber ein
Problem hier ist so viel mehr drin
kriegt man alles nicht alleine hin
deshalb heißt es in diesem Video alles
leer machen alle Bälle sauber machen und
schlussendlich verkaufen am Ende
natürlich um zu schauen wie viel Geld
wir verdienen und ob es tatsächlich
lukrativ ist nach Golfbällen zu tauchen
und sie zu verkaufen
vergesst nicht das Video zu liken um
mich zu supporten und den Kanal zu
abonnieren damit ihr keine der folgenden
Folgen von Porsche Trailer verpasst und
natürlich auch damit ihr immer als
erstes mitbekommt wenn beispielsweise
solche Sachen hier verschenkt werden
dazu aber später im Video mehr
bin ich wieder aber nicht alleine
sondern mit dem besten Fahrradfahrer
ganz Deutschland
mit dem ich damals von Köln bis nach
Paris gefahren bin ist heute dabei aber
nicht in der sondern auch Jan und heute
wird das Gold Business auf die Spitze
getrieben wir haben einen zweiten See
abzusagen den ersten See auch noch
komplett auszunehmen der mehr Zeit im
Gepäck wir haben mehr Leute jetzt geht
es so viel wie möglich heute rauszuholen
was glaubst du wie viel Kohle rausholen
keine Ahnung so 50 € oder so
ich glaube es wird ein bisschen mehr
Tag Nummer zwei Versuch Nummer zwei mit
drei Leuten es werden wieder Golfbälle
gesammelt
es geht los aber nicht alleine sondern
heute zu dritt will nicht wer länger
warten ich will möglichst wenig Zeit an
der frischen Luft an der Kälte verbringt
und wir wissen ja dieser Teich liegt
mitten auf dem Spielfeld also wir stehen
mittendrin guck mal sieht aus als wenn
er schon krank viele neue drin oha und
auch dieses Mal hat der erste Ball nicht
lange auf sich warten müssen
Alter nur die teuren Bälle
war meine stinkt so
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
Joke 4 Minuten drin
das hier ist wirklich so halbe Stunde im
Wasser aber wer man merkt schon wie es
ist jetzt ordentlich ausgedünnt und wir
haben nicht mehr zurück zum
Transportieren mit wir fahren die
Ausbeute jetzt ins Auto schmeißen den
Kofferraum und gehen dann in den zweiten
Tümpel der Antarktis ist wenn die
aufmerksame unter euch werden sich mit
Sicherheit noch erinnern es gibt noch
einen zweiten See und auf dem Weg zu
diesem zweiten See gab es schon die
ersten Kaufinteressenten für unsere
schönen guten Tag wir wollen sie ihre
Bälle wieder haben wie heißt drauf ich
habe gar nicht gewusst dass wir
gemacht hat ja eigentlich verschlagen
ich melde mich sobald wir gleich wieder
daheim sind und dann fangen wir mal zu
sortieren und dann können wir auch
abschätzen wie lange wir brauchen um die
zu sortieren
[Musik]
wie man unschwer erkennen kann ins kalte
Wasser zu springen kann ziemlich
ungemütlich sein und damit Euch und
Euren Finanzen das aber nicht passiert
gibt es scalable capital den Partner des
heutigen Videos scalable capital ist
nicht nur mein persönlicher Broker
sondern auch finanzfluss Testsieger und
ihr könnt super einfach direkt übers
Handy oder über die Desktop Version in
Aktien ETF und viele weitere
Finanzprodukte investieren Account
Erstellung dauert nur wenige Minuten ist
komplett kostenlos und wir können schon
ab 1 € in aktienkrypto und ETF-Sparpläne
investieren mit einer Trading Flatrate
fallen die eh schon geringen oder
Gebühren von 99 Cent dann auch noch weg
außerdem profitiert ihr seit neuestem
davon 2,3 % Zinsen auf euer Guthaben bis
100000 € zu bekommen euer Guthaben ist
das Geld was ihr bei scalable capital
eingezahlt aber noch nicht investiert
habt und das ist ziemlich nice wenn ihr
also anfangen wollte investiert ihr
einen neuen Broker sucht ihr euch
einfach mal mit der App vertraut machen
wollt oder ihr sogar Geld rumliegen habt
für das er bei scalable capital ohne es
zu investieren 2,3% Zinsen bekommt dann
macht das über den ersten Link in der
Videobeschreibung und ladet euch gelbe
capital herunter und wie immer macht es
in eurem eigenen Tempo macht es nur mit
Geld dass ihr wirklich verlieren könnt
und informiert euch guckt euch
finanzflussvideos an und probiert das
Thema wirklich zu verstehen und für euch
den richtigen Weg zu finden wenn ihr
euch also wirklich entscheidet mit dem
investieren starten zu wollen kann es
sehr gut sein das gelbe capital der
richtige Broker für euch ist ist ein
deutsches Unternehmen mit einer
deutschen Bank dahinter und eben wie
gesagt finanzflussfestiger alle Links
dazu hilfreiche Informationen und der
Broker Vergleich von finanzfluss sind
natürlich ganz oben in der
Videobeschreibung vielen Dank ans cable
für die Unterstützung und euch viel Spaß
weiter mit dem Video
[Musik]
zweiter Teich komplett voll größer auch
wieder genau in der Linie der heißt
läuft in der Mitte so zusammen also
theoretisch sollten wir am besten
bedient sein wirklich in die Mitte zu
gehen und dort einfach alles rauszuholen
ja hier liegt auch wieder alles voll
Tipp ist sehr gut wo ich bin auch in
diesem See haben wir eine Menge Bälle
gefunden das Problem war nur Müll Müll
oh nicht so schlimm war eh scheiße
allgemein das Gefühl die Qualität und
die Fülle der Bälle ist hier schlechter
die sehen so ein bisschen schlecht aus
und da einmal mit dem Finger drüber geht
dann erstrahlt das titlist wieder in
eisweiß ich habe eine Ente gefunden
unser Treiben an den Seen blieb auch
nicht lange unbemerkt und wir waren
sowas wie ein Rentner Magnet von denen
die einen dachten sie könnten sich
einfach an unseren Wellen bedienen und
wir würden es nicht mitbekommen
und zum anderen wurden wir Zeuge davon
mir ist eigentlich zustande kommt dass
die sehen so voll sind mit Bällen
guter Schlag mit der Karre komplett voll
von unten bis oben von vorne bis hinten
ging es dann für uns zurück nach Köln
und zum spaßigen Teil dem wirklich
wichtigen Teil für diese Serie zu kommen
mit den Bällen wirklich Geld der Plan
dafür ist so einfach wie genial
Vorwäsche zählen sortieren richtig
waschen und schluss endlich verkaufen
und reich mit einem ganz normalen
Gartenschlauch haben wir uns an die
Vorreinigung gemacht und die Bälle
wirklich vom gröbsten Dreck und vor
allem von dem Gestank aus diesen Zeichen
befreit wir haben auch so viele
sponsor-bälle dabei Porsche Mercedes
irgendwelche Golfclubs vielleicht
sollten wir auch rausbringen
den Schritt zwei haben wir die Bälle
gezählt und uns einen groben Überblick
darüber verschafft wie viele gute und
wie viele unbrauchbare Bälle wir haben
und wir sind schon bei über 2000 Wellen
das große sortieren geht los weiß
alle bellen ein zweites Mal sortieren
und in Marke und vor allem Serie
unterteilt also wirklich innerhalb der
Marken noch mal in einzelnen Kategorien
unterteilt viel Glück
zweimal im Segel landet das war absolute
Unglücks Bälle für Jule wenn du den Ball
wieder erkennst viel Glück Jule meld
dich bei mir Schritt vier dann gründlich
waschen sind auf dem Weg das weiße Gold
zu waschen um nicht zu sagen Geld zu
waschen grundsätzlich wenn man nicht zu
heiß wäscht ist es möglich die Golfbälle
einfach in die Waschmaschine zu tun und
genau das machen wir jetzt und da will
ich bescheid dann machen wir das nicht
zu Hause in unserer Waschmaschine
sondern in einem waschsalat
[Musik]
egal wir können nicht reden bleiben
ach du scheiße ey ich bin richtig
gespannt ob das was wird
ja und jetzt ist er lieber selber
waschen jetzt dreht sich einfach von der
Waschmaschine direkt darum vier
Maschinen Bälle sind in der Waschung ach
du scheiße diesen Scheiß habe ich jetzt
gerade fürs Waschen bezahlt das gehen
wir jetzt erstmal ins Minus in dem
Projekt in der Hoffnung dass es nachher
dann wirklich funktioniert
guckt euch das an das komplett
geisteskrank so kommen die hier raus
also gehen die in die Waschmaschine rein
und so kommen die wieder raus
ach du scheiße und was soll ich sagen
besser hätte es nicht funktionieren
können
[Musik]
wir zu dem Punkt der in der Trader Serie
in den einzelnen Videos immer am meisten
Spaß macht das verkauft
auf der Suche danach wie wir die
Golfbälle am besten verkaufen bin ich
gerade auch einen Ankauf gestoßen die
alle Arten von Golfbällen Lake Balls und
so weiter kaufen und im Zweifelsfall und
die Arbeit abnehmen und alles auf einmal
nehmen cool auf der einen Seite weil wir
weniger Arbeit haben ziemlich schlecht
auf der anderen Seite für unseren Gewinn
aber das finden wir jetzt heraus schönen
guten Tag David henrichter mal parat ich
rufe an da ich ein paar Golfbälle zu
verkaufen hätte
um genau zu sein
2687 Stück
okay um welche Hausnummer würde es sich
bei 2687 Bällen belaufen
10 Cent pro Ball okay vielen dank
schönen Tag noch ich melde mich nochmal
10 Cent pro Ball die kaufen mixt ohne
den jetzt abziehen zu wollen könnte ich
natürlich versuchen die sehr sehr guten
Bälle einzeln zu verkaufen und dann
einen ja will ich mal sagen leicht
angepasst nichts wird
weiterzugeben nach etwas Recherche bin
ich zu folgendem Ergebnis gekommen wie
schon richtig gedacht die markenbälle
bringen natürlich am meisten und wir
müssen uns die Arbeit machen das noch
kleinteiliger aufzuteilen also wir
müssen jetzt alle noch mal nach Marken
sortieren eigentlich innerhalb der
Marken auch noch mal nach dem besten
mittleren und schlechten Willen das
bedeutet das muss noch viel
kleinteiliger sortiert werden in den
einzelnen Marken gibt es auch noch mal
sehr große Unterschiede vor allem bei
Teile haben wir pro V1 das ist so mit
der beste Ball den in noch besser Profi
x hier NXT Tour auch sehr gut dabei und
hier drin liegen jetzt noch AVX drin rum
die ist auch noch mal raus zu sortieren
Geld und zu werden zu einem großen Teil
wahrscheinlich geschlossen in sich
verkauft also 50 Mal Teil des Provinz 50
mal pro v1x und so weiter bei dem Rest
gehen wir auf Marken Mixer also 50 Bälle
gemixt aus Callaway Bridgestones
freaksen weiß und so weiter und diese
Set stellen wir zusammen und laden die
dann auf Kleinanzeigen Hochrufen vor
allem bei den Leuten an die sich schon
auf dem Golfplatz haben uns gemeldet
haben und auch einfach Freunde von
Freunden von Freunden die irgendwas mit
Golf zu tun haben schöne Fotos schöne
Einträge dann eine Menge Geld jetzt
werden alle Leute einfach jeder
angerufen und per Telefon goldbälle
verkauft und wir starten mit der Person
die uns auf dem Golfplatz angesprochen
hat von der wir ja schon wissen dass die
Golfbälle haben möchte
jawoll schönen guten Tag
na unbedingt bis später
kein Verkauf auf Bälle kaufen
für dich ganz entspannte 50 € wir nehmen
jetzt gerade 1 € pro Ball das Zehnfache
von dem was uns für die gesamte Menge
angeboten wurde und jedes Mal wenn ihr
hier diesen Ton hört wie dieser Ball da
rein fällt verdiene ich 1 € und Philipp
mit 1 € mehr machen
die ersten 50 Euro mit Golfbällen das
war wirklich ein toller Preis der
Manager von Max ist so reich dass der
tatsächlich Golf spielt
ich rufe nur an um die Golfbälle zu
verkaufen
fast 40 Euro
40 Euro
und die nächste Bestellung der ich
schwöre die verkaufen sich von alleine
und eigentlich wollen alle nur pro 1 das
ist wirklich scheinbar einfach der Ball
während die Bälle per Telefon super gut
wegging ist auf Ebay quasi nichts
passiert selbst nach einigen Stunden auf
Kleinanzeigen hatten die Anzeigen nur 10
views ungefähr und das hat sich niemand
gemeldet ich meine klar wir haben uns
preislich eine konkurrenzorientiert wir
waren nicht günstiger und eben auch kein
Händler zu dem irgendwer schon Vertrauen
aufgebaut hat warum also bei uns kaufen
und nicht in echten Online Shops wo die
Leute schon Erfahrung mit gutem Service
gutem Versand und guten bellen hat
trotzdem hätte ich aber gedacht dass ich
zumindest ein paar Leute melden aber ist
einfach gar nichts passiert da gibt's
eine Lösung an der Stelle weitermachen
wo es gut funktioniert nämlich am
Telefon über connections über Kumpels
von Kumpels von Kumpels die Golf spielen
oder Golf interessiert sind hat es
unheimlich gut funktioniert die Leute
mitbekommen dass wir weltweit verkaufen
Kumpel der Philipp den ihr gerade eben
schon gesehen habt hat angefangen das
über snapchat an seine Freunde zu
schicken die konnten also genau sehen
welche Bälle wir haben und was alles
möglich ist und wir haben richtig
ordentlich verkauft und genauso im
Golfclub in Aachen scheint es so ein
bisschen Runde gemacht haben also genau
da wo wir die Bälle aus dem Wasser
geholt haben die Leute wollten scheinbar
ihre Bälle zurückkaufen ja ja
beispielsweise hat uns angerufen und für
einen Kumpel ganz spezielle weißbälle
bestellt die haben wir raus sortiert und
so weiter also es hat sich tatsächlich
so ein bisschen verbreitet
[Musik]
aber was heißt ein bisschen ein bisschen
viel um nicht zu sagen 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11
Bestellungen konnten wir verkaufen in
unterschiedlicher Größe in
unterschiedlicher Zusammensetzung und
Qualität aber insgesamt 11 Bestellungen
mit der teuersten Bestellung von knapp
200 € für alle titelist prov1xbälle was
völlig krank ist das macht einen
Gesamtumsatz und jetzt haltet euch fest
von
659 € ohne Versandkosten die kamen noch
drauf die habe ich aber jetzt nicht mit
eingerechnet weil es sonst einfach zu
undurchsichtig geworden wäre minus 32 €
für unseren sehr professionellen
Waschgang - 17,28 € für 18 kW die wir
mit dem Auto nach Aachen hin und zurück
zweimal aus dem ersten und dem zweiten
Video Verfahren haben ergibt 600 9 € und
72 Cent an gewinnen was völlig verrückt
ist weil wir immer noch Golfbälle haben
weil wir immer noch eine Menge Golfbälle
haben wir wie wir alle wissen für zehn
Cent pro Stück an diesen einen Typen
verkaufen könnten und das Problem quasi
sofort loswerden Updates zu weiteren
Verkäufen wenn wir es denn hinbekommen
in den nächsten Folgen vergesst also
nicht den Kanal zu abonnieren damit ihr
das nicht verpasst vielen Dank für euren
Geisteskranken Support auf die erste
Folge lasst den Video ein Like da wir
sehen uns nächste Woche Sonntag wieder
macht's gut Ciao
naja da war ja noch was ich habe 150
dieser Golfbälle hier bedrucken lassen
das sind Callaway Golfbälle mit dem
Aufdruck Dave Porsche Trader als kleines
Andenken und großes Dankeschön von mir
an euch dass ihr die Serie so gut
annehmt dass wir alle gemeinsam so viel
Spaß an den Videos haben und diese Bälle
sind über den Link in der
Videobeschreibung kostenlos zu bestellen
seid schnell sind nur 150 und ich
wünsche euch viel Spaß damit als kleines
Andenken kleines Merching für null Euro
finde ich das ziemlich cool